joining me now is the president of the
national action network
and host of msnbc's politic politics
nation reverend al sharpton
so rev you've been at the forefront of
efforts to address
poverty crime police brutality for
decades i mean all of these
issues uh in a lot of ways are
interconnected
um in from your vantage point how has
joe biden changed on the issue of crime
from 1991 up to the present well
i watched carefully his an attorney
general garland's statement today
because i protested the 94 crime bill
almost 34 years ago when as you
correctly said
most of the congressional black caucus
and many civil rights leaders
supported it uh a lot of the reaction
was to the high crime at the time
which all of us wanted to deal with but
we did not feel that three strikes send
you out
and uh giving disparate disproportionate
sentences
to people with crack cocaine as opposed
to loose cocaine
was was the answer and it was going to
lead to what it did lead to
mass incarceration today they did not go
at the end of the crime line as much as
they did the beginning which is what we
talked about in the early 90s
they talked about guns they talked about
how the guns get
into our community they talked about
dealing with manufacturing
and gun laws and i think that that is a
wiser approach but i would hasten to add
jelena
that they need to make sure as they put
these things
into place that they also pass
laws like the george floyd criminal uh
policing act so that we do not create an
atmosphere
where police are therefore let loose
with no federal laws that tell them how
far they could go
while they confiscate the guns or go
after the gun manufacturers
they must win this whole question of gun
violence
with police legislation
because just like we were in the era i
mean no one could have laid it out
better than you did tonight
we were in the era of high crime we were
in the era of rodney king
in this time we're in the era of rising
gun violence
tick uh uh up and gun violence and
george floyd
and we can't make the same mistake where
we have
a on an imbalance in how we react to one
and not balance it with the other
right so do you think that this
administration particularly with the
addition of senator kamala harris who
comes from a background
as a prosecutor but also has actually a
really different perspective
even as a prosecutor on what are some of
the
solutions to crime and in some ways
i feel like this administration has
adjusted the perspective it's
thinking about what are the causes of
crime
right guns poverty lack of education
lack of housing lack of resources
as opposed to simply focusing on the
punishment
for crimes as a deterrent to crime is
that
is that a good summation of sort of the
shift you see
and even how this administration talks
about the solutions versus how
you know senator joe biden used to talk
about it which frankly feels outdated
i think that uh you would have to say
that uh
vice president harris brings a different
perspective
which is good and and gives some
balancing
and i also think that uh joe biden
himself has grown and has
openly said that the uh a crime bill of
94 was not
uh done right and that he could see
where
uh now they should have done things
differently he came to uh
national national martin luther king
breakfast in 19
2019 and openly uh said where he was
wrong
and aspects of the crime bill so i think
some of that he's seen
the results of what was done i think the
congressional black caucus
that was supported in 94 is not
supportive now
without these restraints like a george
floyd bill
so i think the climate is different the
reality though
and the thing that bothers us the most
is that
blacks live in the worst of both worlds
we
are afraid of the cops and the rockers
and we need
our laws that will save us from both
in terms of the conversations that
you've had recently with the white house
what what are if you can share some of
the conversations you've had about the
issue of crime
i know that you've had a lot of
conversations about the policing
bill that is being considered in the
senate and you've met recently with the
administration but has the issue of
you know the rising crime that's
happening around the country right now
has that come up
in your discussions i've talked to
cedric richmond at the white house about
it
who has his ear to the ground i think he
has a sensitivity
uh that is good uh to be there on the
west wing
and i think that uh he is very sensitive
to the fact
that we need to deal with this with
balance and that they're going to have
to do community policing they
need the validators of those of us that
are on the ground
that works in these communities every
day
because all of this is built on as any
community on trust
and i think he understands that
partnership so i'm comfortable
with cedric richmond being right in the
middle of these conversations
but again the proof is going to be an
important we need both
legislations done we need whatever
they're going to do with policing
and we need whatever they're going to do
about policing
to be done at the same time you can't do
one and then the other
and then you in that gap may have some
incidents
that would all turn it all the way
around
right it feels to me like if you don't
have a balanced
um approach to this you would end up
like we did in the 90s with you throw
money at the problem
you just send a whole bunch of police
officers
and that actually doesn't do much too i
mean the crime rate did fall
but i would argue actually that it's not
because of the increased presence of
police
um that was deterring crime other
conditions changed
um do you think that the administration
understands that they can't just add
more police officers to the to the
streets to solve this problem that they
need that nuanced and balanced approach
that you're talking about
no i think that i think they do in my
conversations
uh they be they certainly the vice
president understands
enrichment does and i think in the
conversation i had with biden
about the george floyd bill and uh we
had a few minutes
when he spoke in tulsa i think he gets
it the question is can they get the
senate
to pass this george floyd bill and can
they be
can they balance it but the worst thing
in the world is to add more police
without having the restraints
on police or the guidelines of what is
bad policing this friday
we are going to sentence uh derek chovin
to jail a policeman who killed george
floyd this friday
so in the middle of the president making
a speech today
and a good one about gun violence two
days later we're putting a policeman in
jail
in the same week so we need to
understand that we walk
with both feet we can't hop and then
expect that we have had a balanced walk
unless we don't have the other
elect those of us that don't but we have
the
ability that both legs of the criminal
justice work simultaneously
and we ought to do that and we ought to
insist on that otherwise
we're going to end up with the same
results we ended up with 30 years ago
and it is not wise to make the same
mistake again
that is right that is absolutely right
uh reverend al sharpton thank you so
much for taking the time out i know
you're
very busy person uh thank you for taking
the time please stay safe
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching